the realm
do you know what the realm is
it's the thousand blades of aegon's
enemies
a story we agreed to tell each other
over
and over till we forget that it's a lie
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another game of thrones and
house of the dragon video
as you all know hbo is developing a new
series about the dance of dragons set
roughly 170 years before the events of
game of thrones
house of the dragon will feature the
targaryen civil war
when this major house nearly made itself
go extinct
i'm sure most of you have already seen
some of my videos about the show
if my sources are right filming on house
of the dragon should begin within the
next few weeks
once that happens we should be getting
new updates almost every single day
i was actually expecting more
announcements already from hbo
they should be almost done with filling
out the rest of their cast and crew
since we're only weeks away from the
filming start date
now if you have read a song of ice and
fire as well as fire and blood
you will already have a good idea of
what major events this series will
feature
as of right now we haven't heard much
from the actors writers directors or
anyone else working on the show for that
matter
that was until now one of the stars from
the upcoming series gave some of her
thoughts during a recent interview
i figured i would show you what she said
so you can stay up to date with any and
all information about the show
now before i show you what she said i do
want to let everyone know i am writing
my own version of game of thrones season
9.
some of you may have already seen my
video where i wrote my own version of
the game of thrones ending
well since so many fans were left
feeling unsatisfied with how things did
end
i decided i would write another season
giving some of my ideas on what
direction i think the show could go in
based on where dan and dave ended the
story now i must admit
it will not be easy fixing some of the
things they did
but i look at it as a writing exercise
because i basically have to write myself
out of a corner either way it should be
fun i have already made one video where
i wrote the opening scene
since so many of you said you are
interested in hearing me right the rest
of the season that is what i will do
next
i just wanted to thank everyone for
supporting that idea
now let me show you what actress olivia
cook said about house of the dragon
as well as the game of thrones fandom
the headline reads
house of the dragon star olivia cook
believes the show won't have
egregious violence against women you
know depending on how you look at this
she drops a minor spoiler during the
interview i will show you what i mean
once we get there
during an interview with the british
news outlet olivia cook spoke about
house of the dragon
hbo's upcoming new series about the
dance of dragons
the targaryen civil war that occurred
hundreds of years before
ned stark journeyed to king's landing
and made some very bad decisions
the actress said the show makes her
nervous because of the reaction to the
game of thrones final season which is
understandable
what olivia actually said was i'm a bit
nervous about the new one
you're never gonna make everyone happy
so i've just gotta not listen to that
stuff
as you all know there was so much
outrage over the final season of game of
thrones it has some of the actors on the
new series very nervous
we all know the writing is really out of
their hands all they can do is their own
job to the best of their ability
but if the writing sucks then the entire
show as a whole gets seen in a negative
light
i think i can speak for a lot of game of
thrones fans when i say the acting
the sets the special effects the score
the wardrobe
and almost everything else was
phenomenal the one thing that was
holding it back was the writing
game of thrones had a chance of being
the greatest show ever made
i know i still rank it high on my list
even with the controversial ending
but it would be number one on almost
everyone's list
if they had nailed their landing what i
do like about olivia admitting this
is the fact that we know they have hurt
us dan and dave have always said they
don't go online reading criticism about
themselves or the show
but the fans were so loud after they
released their ending
it could not be avoided if you start
listening
to every every criticism
it'll tear what you do apart because the
criticisms are many of them mutually
exclusive to people
they're going to be people who think
it's moving too quickly they're going to
be people who think it's moving too
slowly people who
think there's too much violence people
who think there's not enough violence
and we just we make the show that we
want to watch i can't stand the wailing
of women
one word and i hit you again i'm telling
mother
hbo knows we were upset with how
everything was rushed i
just really hope they take this into
consideration because if any of their
writers ever try to do that again
someone needs to step in and make sure
it doesn't happen
you either need to throw more money at
them or hire new writers altogether
new writers who would care about ending
things the right way
we will see if hbo learns from their
mistakes if you ask me
i think they have been listening to us
fans they have made some good moves for
house of the dragon already
they know we all love the music on game
of thrones so they brought back their
amazing composer to score their new
series
they also know that most of us love
miguel sapochnick who directed some of
game of thrones best episodes
not only did they bring him back they
made him one of the showrunners
i feel like they made those choices
because they knew it's what a lot of
people wanted
now let me show you what else was said
because it could be seen as a minor
spoiler
after she said she was nervous about the
fan's reaction the article goes on to
say
she could take some solace in the fact
that unlike game of thrones
house of the dragon already has an
ending the lengthy conflict has already
been mapped out in full by george rr
martin in fire and blood
although it reads much more like a
history book of westeros than a novel
more importantly olivia cook thinks
house of the dragon won't be featuring
gratuitous scenes of violence against
women
which was the biggest criticism of game
of thrones at least until the final
season aired
olivia said i wouldn't feel comfortable
if i was in a series that had
egregious graphic violence against women
for no reason whatsoever
just because they wanted it to be
tantalizing in a way that gets viewers
now here's where she drops the minor
spoiler she also said
i was lucky enough to read the script
before and it has changed a lot from the
first few seasons
i don't think they'd be in their right
minds to include any of that anymore
what i think she means here is the first
season of house of the dragon will be
different from the first few seasons of
game of thrones
at least when it comes to violence
against women now she wasn't very
specific
about what scene she was referring to
but for some reason i feel like she
might have been referring to what
happened to dany
and sansa on their wedding nights those
were some very big differences from the
books
for whatever reason dan and dave decided
they could go further with these scenes
by having those things happen to sansa
and danny
in the books the ramsay scene is
actually much worse if you ask me but it
doesn't involve
sansa at all it actually happens to
sansa's childhood friend
and like i said the daenerys scene is
also different
drogo doesn't force himself on her the
same way he does in the show
when you think about what she said she
is right there was no good reason for
them to do that
not only were there a lot of fans upset
but so was george rr martin
he has given his thoughts on those
scenes and interviews before
now i will say she doesn't really spoil
anything by letting us know what would
happen
but more so of what wouldn't happen she
has read the first season
or at least the first episode and as far
as she knows we won't be seeing anything
like that
hbo is aware of the many mistakes that
were made during game of thrones so
you'd like to think that they would
avoid making them again
they should know they have their work
cut out for them if they want to get
back all the viewers they once had
i just hope they don't go too far in the
other direction by making the show super
soft
nowadays you have to walk a very fine
line even when it is seen as art
hopefully we will get more updates soon
if filming does begin in a few weeks we
should be finding out what other actors
and characters will be in the show
as always i will let you know any and
all new information that gets released
for now i will go back to writing my own
version of game of thrones season 9
and i want to thank all of you for your
continued support have a great day
everyone i will see you soon
bye
[Music]
[Music]
you